Not all Star Wars rumors are created equal.
Many of the ideas out there for Episode IX,
while fun to consider, are just too outlandish
to stand a chance at being real.
Other rumors, though, sound all too plausible
— and that's not necessarily a good thing.
One new report making the rounds is raising
serious concerns among franchise fans, getting
people worried that the saga-concluding sequel
might just be a tired rehash of Return of
the Jedi.
According to a report popularized by YouTuber
Mike Zeroh, Episode 9 will include a gigantic,
planet-destroying weapon —yes, again.
The rumor hinges around a purportedly leaked
scene description from the untitled ninth
Star Wars episode, which goes into detail
about the attributes of the supposed superweapon.
The scene reportedly centers on Kylo Ren,
now the Supreme Leader of the villainous First
Order, sitting in a room at what seems to
be the organization's headquarters.
He's said to be analyzing a hologram displaying
a yet-to-be-completed array of superweapons.
According to the leak, the son of Han and
Leia will be seen sizing up three weapons
shaped like cylinders with large engines,
blasting blue and red energy, watching as
they destroy the terrain of an unknown world.
While the weapon appears capable of immense
destructive power, it also seems to still
be under construction.
Sound familiar?
Some have noted that the rumored weapon sounds
strikingly similar to a World Devastator,
which is a form of technology featured in
the old Star Wars expanded universe — particularly
the Star Wars Legends "Dark Empire" storyline.
Designed by Imperial engineers who helped
craft the original Death Star, the World Devastators
are described as weapons that land on planets
and use tractor beam technology to rip the
land apart, decimating everything in their
reach.
While the Death Stars were incredibly effective
mass-killing machines, the World Devastators
take things one step further by extracting
the rubble from destroyed planets.
The weapon ships, armed to the teeth with
guns, lasers, missiles, ion cannons, and more,
would harvest the remnants of ravaged worlds
for fuel and resources, which would then be
used to power the ships' engines.
The salvaged material also would also serve
as fuel for the ships' internal foundries,
which were used to create more cruisers, droids,
and destructive weapons.
While the World Devastators aren't currently
a part of Disney's revived Star Wars canon,
there's nothing stopping Episode IX director
J.J. Abrams from digging through the series'
history books and bringing past elements back
into the fold.
But just because it's plausible doesn't mean
that fans want to see it happen on screen.
If the new movie really does feature yet another
giant weapon based on Death Star tech, it
would feel remarkably similar to Return of
the Jedi, not to mention the original Star
Wars movie, or The Force Awakens.
While that seventh Star Wars episode, also
directed by Abrams, was praised for how it
reignited that classic Star Wars after years'
worth of weird prequels, many rolled their
eyes at the inclusion of Starkiller Base — a
bigger, badder Death Star in everything but
name.
After the divisive response to The Last Jedi,
which tried to take the series in some controversial
new directions, as well as the muted reaction
to the Han Solo spinoff, it's possible that
Disney and Lucasfilm will want to play things
safe for the series' ninth episode.
Maybe the idea is to go back to what worked
before, instead of risk alienating people
again with something new.
But as the fan reaction to the rumor seems
to indicate, there is such a thing as being
too familiar.
Some people are even making arguments in support
of the prequel movies, which at the very least
seemed to try new things, even though they
didn't always stick the landing.
To many viewers, Star Wars should be about
more than just laser swords, Death Stars,
and Darth Vader.
Going back to that well too many times seems
to speak to a lack of imagination, and even
risks turning people off the series for good.
But is this rumor true?
We don't know, but it feels believable, and
that's what has fans worried.
Star Wars is supposed to offer a whole galaxy
of ideas, not just the same one, over and
over.
It's hard to imagine anyone being satisfied
with another superweapon serving up the climax
of the decade-spanning Skywalker Saga.
There's no way Episode 9 will satisfy everybody,
but can't it at least try to surprise us?
We can only hope.
We'll find out for sure what's going down
when the movie hits theaters on December 20th,
2019.